one of the things that the national
assessment of educational progress does
you know going back to the early 70s the
tracks kind of student scores uh they've
been pretty flat and depending on how he
calculated we're spending two to three
times as much per pupil in real
inflation-adjusted terms is it just that
kids are Dumber now
that we have to spend more and more
money on them to keep them at the same
or slightly lower level than when you
and I Robert were you know in short
pants Zach was not quite born yet at his
SATs I guarantee you are better than
mine probably yours you know but uh no
but I mean is it is it a yeah no that's
for sure is it I mean you know it's it's
a weird thing like are we are we
obsessing over education in a way and
I'm joking about kids just being Dumber
but you know because education you know
going back to Socrates you know
educating the young is absolutely filled
with existential anxiety of every
society and you know so is all of this
just kind of like you know we're just we
got a lot of nervous energy and a lot of
money to spend and a lot of time to
argue but you know actually the kids are
doing okay
uh I I don't think the kids are doing
okay and I don't want to be alarmist
about this something we haven't even
touched on is mental health you know and
if you talk to John Hyde and Greg
Luciano and others they'll say it's it's
the screen is stupid and I think there's
a compelling case for for the
deleterious effects of social media and
technology and whatnot you know so it's
almost impossible to separate schools
from all the other effects in kids lives
um do I think kids have gotten some real
kids have not gotten Dumber kids have
gotten smarter
um do I think we have gotten
accidentally less good at educating them
probably uh and and it probably has to
do with some of the factors we talked
about earlier Nick about how it was
there didn't used to be a lot of
question about what you did in school
all day and the more sophisticated we've
gotten in terms of trying to raise
levels of you know problem solving and
critical thinking we've actually got
made it worse not better you've got the
issue of of who becomes a teacher
um you know nobody should want women to
to to to leave Law and medicine and
whatnot and go back into the classroom
but but if you think about I'll bet like
you like me Nick some of your teachers
in retrospect were women who today would
have been doing much more renumerative
things than they did 40 or 50 years ago
it's a gordian not you know I I'm taking
Austin you know the amount of
environmental lead was so much higher
you know and Lead gets a bad rap but I
don't know when you know when we were
chewing on lead paint and breathing in
lead gasoline air fumes I don't know we
seemed to be doing better as a uh as a
society yeah look the the one this will
be my Parting Shot I guess the the one
if if I could make one change in
American Education now it would probably
be and this gets to the idea of is it
getting it is is it getting worse I
think what's changes our expectations
have gotten
um uh outsized for American education
and and most specifically what I mean by
that is we literally expect too much not
of education but of teachers we keep
asking them to do more and more and the
same and I look I mean this is the the
last hill I'll die on in education I
pointed this out all the time you've got
four million American men and women in
classrooms every day if you have four
million of anybody doing anything by
definition you're going to have a normal
range of human capacity in in a number
that large so you've got to make that
job doable by those people the Cavalry
isn't coming there are not enough Saints
and Superstars to to fill all those
classrooms we've got to reconceive the
job of of teacher to be doable by men
and women of ordinary sentience because
that's who we have and that's all we're
ever going to have so if the job can't
be done well by those people you you
don't have a plan it's a prayer
hey I'm nicholasby with reason if you
liked what you saw there please click on
the link below in the show notes and
watch our entire live stream with Robert
pondicio of AEI talking about school
choices promises and perils every
Thursday Zach weismiller and I do a live
stream a live unscripted conversation
anything can happen anything can be said
they are always interesting with
policymakers book authors people who are
making a difference in the world hope to
see you next Thursday